getting the grades is great but paying
the price for a university place is the
next challenge
some universities say domestic tuition
fees have to go up
i think what we need to be clear about
is that university fees have been frozen
for 10 years now at the 9 250 level so
obviously in the current environment
that's extremely difficult for
universities to be able to you know to
be able to fund all the activities that
we do do so it's a really sort of tricky
time there's been media reports today of
24 000 pound fees i mean i think that
nobody in the sector is really seriously
talking about that level of increase but
you know potentially around 12 000 or so
but again we do need to sort of really
think about what level is right and what
is the right mix to ensure a really
vibrant and viable system
tuition fees have risen since 1998 from
one thousand pounds they trebled in 2006
and traveled again in 2012 to just below
where they are today
earlier this year the government put a
price cap on tuition fees setting it at
9250 pounds for the next two years but
some universities say that means that
for every home student they take they're
making a loss of more than 1700 pounds
and that by 2024 that loss more than
doubles to 4 000.
but there is already significant
financial pressure for students as
prices for them as for everyone continue
to rise from rent to bills to food
student finance can cover fees and there
are maintenance loans to help with
living costs but danielle a third year
student says the prospect of ending up
with so much debt is already making
people think twice
people just think
is this worth
my degree like is my degree worth
this much money even if tuition fees
might go up but it's the
maintenance loan that also would need to
kind of reflect that as well because a
lot of the time that's what um people
struggle with especially with the
cost of living crisis no domestic
tuition fee hike may mean more overseas
students according to some university
bosses they already pay more than double
and some unis are already taking on
record numbers but the department of
education says it's a myth that uk
students will miss places as a result
there's no comment from them about
addressing the price cap issue
catherine vertotsi sky news